hey guys Ted Mars in here and if you
haven't seen Deadpool go see it it's
exactly a Deadpool movie we've been
waiting for it's so funny it has a ton
of 4th wall breaking like me right now
and a lot of hilarious references to the
comic book movies and Ryan Reynolds
career the biggest joke of all just
kidding Ryan you are a great great great
looking guy what is your secret anyway
we're going to cover all of that stuff
in another video but first we're going
to explain to you the post-credit scene
let's break it down so Deadpool pops
into a hallway wearing a bathrobe and he
seems surprised to see the audience he
says you're still here it's over go home
but he realizes we're waiting for the
standard Marvel post-credit teaser and
he tells us Oh expecting a teaser for
Deadpool to what we don't have that kind
of money then Deadpool calls out the
other Marvel teaser scenes be expected
Sam Jackson show up I'm passionate saucy
the Lebanon her kind of yeah this post
credit scene is a direct reference to
the one that's in Ferris Bueller's Day
Off a 1986 comedy starring Matthew
Broderick this movie was a huge
influence on Deadpool and his metahuman
it has a ton of fourth wall breaking
where Ferris Bueller's talking directly
to the camera like it was pretty bad and
it has one of the first post-credit
scenes ever so Deadpool is paying
tribute to that here by doing what
Matthew did back in the 80s the scenes
exactly the same I mean look at the
bathroom the hallway even the lines
you're still here you're still here it's
over it's over go home uh-huh oh it's
just really fun to see Deadpool
reference this classic film and pay
homage to the people that started at all
but there's more there's a second part
to the scene that actually does give us
a little bit of a teaser he says but I
can tell you one thing and it's a bit of
a secret this equal we're gonna have
cable Mandy character and he's right
cable is an amazing character with a
long history with the x-men and Deadpool
but who is he who is cable well he's the
son of Cyclops and Madeleine prior who's
a clone of Jean Grey now he's a bit
older when we meet him he has
telekinetic and telepathic abilities and
he has a techno-organic armed with super
strength and an infrared eye and he's a
time traveler you can travel through
time that's awesome that's why Professor
Xavier gay
him that name cable he's the link
between the present and the future so in
the comics cable uses his powers and
knowledge of future events try to
prevent super villains from rising to
power like apocalypse but the most
exciting stuff is when cable and
deadpool team up and they have their own
series and their own adventures it's
really fun you got to check it out
there's one where cable and deadpool
have to deal with a virus that turns
everyone blue there's one where cable
and deadpool out to teleport to
different dimensions and find a baby
version of cable there's one more cable
and deadpool try to get laid that just
sounds like a normal story but the other
ones are pretty crazy point is there's a
ton of awesome material in the comics
that would make for a great movie
between cable and deadpool plus they're
just a fun team to see together I really
want to see it I know it's gonna be a
good movie plus it'd be really fun to
have cables first appearance in the MCU
be in a Deadpool movie rather than
another x-men movie where we have
another super serious future saving
soldier trying to stop time travel and
all the bad bosses if he's in a Deadpool
movie then we get to have a little more
fun we get to break the universe more I
want to see that now who should they
cast us cable Deadpool himself gave us a
few ideas in the scene we have no idea
we're gonna cast yet but it could be
anything you see the big guy with
flattop Mel Gibson Dolph Lundgren Keira
Knightley he's got ready to know so guys
this movie is gonna happen the sequels
confirmed robert life the artist who
created both Deadpool and cable we did a
Photoshop mock-up of the actor he wants
to play the part I gotta say Jon Hamm
and Ryan Reynolds together as a buddy
comedy that would be a perfect buddy
comedy and to finish a scene Deadpool
wins the hearts of movie theater Usher's
everywhere reminding us take our trash
out because otherwise to total geek and
he finishes up with one more Ferris
Bueller reference there's a line from
the song oh yeah by yellow which is in
Ferris Bueller's Day Off
it's a great song to listen to great
pump up jam especially if you're a
stripper first time on the pole highly
recommend it so that's the post-credits
scene from Deadpool we didn't get a cool
visual tease or a huge cameo that we get
in other MCU movies we didn't get Nick
Fury and a sexy little leather number
and we didn't get Hugh Jackman with his
sideburns we've got Deadpool doing what
he does best screw at the audience but
we did learn that there's a cool sequel
coming out and it was funny it was very
Deadpool so that's what I liked about it
it's a good post credit scene in my book
and I should know I wrote the book on
post-credits scenes yeah I'm a doctor if
you need more Deadpool we've got you
covered you can check out our who is
Deadpool video with so many great videos
coming up I'm excited about the one
where we break down every reference in
the Deadpool movie there's so many of
them it's like a freaking Wayans
brothers movie except funny guys let me
know what you thought of Deadpool down
in the comments i loved it i was
laughing so much i recently built a
coolin IKEA dresser so that scene had me
cracking up IKEA furniture is not easy
all right follow me on twitter at Ted
Marcin and follow us at new rock stars
will keep you up with when our new
videos are coming out and that's it now
if you'll excuse me I'm gonna go sing oh
yeah full volume oh yeah ball-ball Oh
bow bow bow bow